how you doing Andy good Rich how you
doing brother hi Jonathan hi hey nice to
meet you nice to meet you too question
for you on the domestic violence civil
protection orders that you see that
you've dealt with and over the years I
know this is a tough question but how
many of those what percentage would you
guess are actually real where there's a
true threat of domestic violence and the
reason that I'm asking you this question
is my ex-wife tried the Silver Bullet
method on me and um amazingly it didn't
work on an ex-part basis and it didn't
work after a full hearing and I believe
that it's a big big problem that we have
not only here in the States but
unplugged talks about it in Canada a guy
from New Zealand just talked about it
guys are just scared to death to co even
cohabitate anymore I'll never do it
again I can't take the risk that you're
going to wake up one day get ticked off
and go downtown and say that I tried to
do something crazy like happened one
time so how many of them would you say
that you've seen are actually legit
uh off the top of my head
twenty percent roughly uh not not the
majority I'll tell you that now there
are cases where someone's coming in on
crutches or they got hit with a baseball
bat that is different but a vast
majority
like the burden is putting someone in in
fear of imminent serious bodily injury
and I've seen cases where it's about to
go in front of a judge or the people
will check in and then the woman will
sit in the courthouse or in the
courtroom and she'll withdraw it on her
own realizing that the judge has is too
experienced to buy her story that
doesn't happen all the time but I've
seen it I've also seen many cases where
the plaintiff or the complainant doesn't
show up to the final hearing because
there's an initial ex parte hearing
which just the complainant and the judge
and a lot not all of the now yours if I
heard you're right that wasn't even
granted we're the judge neither right
and she still went ahead to a final
hearing and that wasn't granted either
nope wow it's just and it's amazing she
had four and a half pages you know on
the very end of those you can write you
know you write the incident of what you
think happened it was four and a half
pages and you would have thought I was
Jeffrey Dahmer
right it was bad sometimes I'll see
people file them and go to a hearing and
they'll complain about something that
happened two years ago
like he threatened me two years ago well
where have you been for the last couple
of years you know and some of the
stories are just they don't reach the
level of what I would consider putting
someone in fear of serious bodily injury
or imminent serious bodily injury so
that's just like off the top of my head
not not a majority at all I didn't think
so I don't know if you saw it in uh the
Texas Longhorns basketball coach just
was fired for a false DV charge that she
they got into a verbal argument and she
called the cops and said he strangled
her he was put on administrative leave
and when she figured out that oh gosh
he's going to lose the 30 million dollar
contract she redacted that and said it
never happened well the Board of
Trustees still fired him because he
represents it's too late now so ring the
bell no in one final funny thing it
amazes me like in the case of my ex-wife
they do this CPO falsified domestic
violence they drag you through the
grinder and then when it's all over they
go okay well you need to be nice to me
now going forward it's like oh
their entitlement is amazing to me right
I've had cases where the guide will have
his mom or his uh friend drive the kid
to the custody exchange because he does
because she's made a false claim against
him and he doesn't want to be anywhere
near her no matter what you know blocks
are on social media blah I would advise
that to do that too I mean I won't I
won't even speak to her we haven't
spoken in a year and a half and my dad
does all the pickups for me he picks him
up because I will not even I do not even
want to look at you I don't even want to
breathe the air that you're breathing
get away from me right I don't blame you
that's the safest spot to be in yeah
it's not good for the kids either I mean
like you know like now your kids are
growing up in a household where Dad
can't even communicate with Mom and
granddad's got to do all the pickup sort
of thing like it's tough like like it's
a like it's a very difficult predicament
because they put the law in place to
protect women but then because there's
no real checks and balances all they
have to do is point and sputter and say
man big and bad I scared and you know
boom you're in cuffs and you know you're
hauled away and the locks are changed so
it's it's uh
it was a no-win situation it was about
the way that she went about it rich if
you just would have came to me and said
look Andy I'm in over my head I don't
have training education discipline to be
able to handle these two kids while
you're grinding I really never liked you
to begin with in my hypergamy is kicked
in big time I would have been like okay
well thanks for telling me there's the
door well therein lies that you're
therein lies a woman to become rational
my friend it's not possible okay well
let me move you with Jack Nicholson you
know he was cornered you know some woman
said how do you write women so well and
he goes I think of a man and I take away
accountability and rationality or
something like that right it's like you
know you're wishing for something that
doesn't doesn't exist unfortunately but
you know you know you went through the
process I'm sure you're better off for
it I know it's difficult but uh you know
fair fair warning guys you know here you
have another example right yeah your
situation is more common than people
think here people have their parents
take the kids uh because they don't want
to be anywhere on her radar when I
unplugged from The Matrix I really
discovered that see I thought I was the
only one at the time that this happened
to it happens every day all day all the
time but I didn't know that until I
unplugged yeah yeah the courts are
filled with these kind of cases so
question question before you go Andy
it's it sounds like you know my stuff
how many red flags did she have before
you married her like were any of them
obvious to you already counted them it
was 14. and then my very similar Rich
Cooper scenario I did the single mommy
routine afterwards that was 16 of them
yeah
well one step at a time my friend
one step at a time
I'll see you gents later thanks thank
you I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out